With superheroes dominating the box office
around the world, the average movie fan can
probably tell you the biggest points in any
superhero’s origin story.
But the origin stories and classic comic arcs
that every fan knows by heart are usually
the ones the publisher wants them to remember.
Even the brightest heroes tend to have some
dark stories in their past.
And when we say dark, we mean so dark, fans
will wonder why they were ever published in
the first place.
Here are Screenrant’s DARK Stories About
The Most Popular Superheroes.
Spider-Man: Sins Past (Marvel)
Thanks to the Amazing Spider-Man movie series,
even non comic fans know just how beloved
and innocent Peter Parker's first girlfriend
Gwen Stacy was - which made her death at the
hands of Green Goblin so shocking.
But when J Michael Straczynski told the Marvel
editors he wanted to give Peter an adult child
Gwen had delivered in secret, they turned
him down, wanting to keep the illusion that
Peter was still a young man.
Instead, the change to Gwen's secret past
was a bit more complicated – and a lot less
logical.
Apparently, Gwen found herself so attracted
to Harry Osborn’s father Norman, she spontaneously
slept with him while she and Peter were together.
That's right, Norman Osborn impregnated a
teenage Gwen Stacy.
When she promised the madman that he would
never see his children and would raise them
with Peter, he suited up as Goblin one last
time, leading to her death in issue #121.
Changing the past happens all the time in
comics, but this story left most fans outraged
and upset - not to mention in need of a hot
shower.
Superman: The Suicide Snare (DC Comics)
There's no greater love story than Mister
Miracle and Big Barda, two children of Apokolips
who fell in love, and escaped to Earth.
That was until writer John Byrne had Barda
end up kidnapped by Sleez, a former minion
of Darkseid with...even darker tastes.
Using mind control, he doesn't seek to beat
or even kidnap Barda, but strip her down,
and make an adult film of her dancing in his
sewer.
By the time her husband finds out – with
one video hand-delivered by Darkseid - Superman
is already on the case.
Actually, he's been brainwashed to co-star
with Barda in Sleez's next movie.
Mister Miracle breaks in just in time, leaving
readers to wonder what could possibly have
made this story seem like one that should
ever be told, let alone one starring Superman
himself.
On the plus side, it shows Superman isn’t
always a gentleman: instead of explaining
or uncovering what happened, they all go their
separate ways.
Because, you know, he’s Superman.
Green Lantern: Emerald Twilight (DC Comics)
When DC decided to kill off Barry Allen, they
had the speedster sacrifice himself to save
the universe.
But when it came to his best friend Hal Jordan,
the writers tried something different.
Instead of a sacrifice, readers watched as
his home Coast City was turned to ash along
with the millions who lived there.
When the Green Lantern Corps refused to let
him bring the dead back to life, Hal went
on a killing spree.
The greatest Lantern slaughtering the entire
corps and all except one of their Guardians
would eventually be rewritten to spare Hal
any blame, claiming he had been “infected”
with an embodiment of fear, and driven insane.
But there's no way to forget that DC once
turned a Justice League superstar into a bloodthirsty
murderer on a galactic level.
Spider-Man & The Power Pack (Marvel)
The 1980s and 90s saw tons of comics reaching
out to kids, teaching them to steer clear
of drugs, alcohol, or even physical abuse.
So it isn’t hard to see why Marvel chose
to use their famous webslinger for such a
good cause.
In a 1984 issue, Peter Parker rescues his
young neighbor from his babysitter, sharing
a story form his own childhood.
Apparently, Peter became friends with an older
boy named Skip Westcott when he was around
12 years old.
One day Skip showed Peter some adult magazines,
and pressured him into acting out the pictures
themselves.
Saying he was “too frightened to leave,”
it would be years before Peter realized he
shouldn’t be ashamed.
It was a strong message to send to young readers,
but ever since, fans have debated just how
much of the Spider-Man identity was a result
of the abuse.
And it’s no surprise that Marvel has decided
to keep that side of his character out of
the live-action movies.
Batman: Venom (DC Comics)
These days, the strength-enhancing drug called
“Venom” is tied directly to Bane, the
Batman villain who uses it to grow to insane
size and strength.
But the drug was introduced long before Bane
got his hands on it, in a comic meant to show
Bruce Wayne’s earlier days of costumed crime-fighting.
In Legends of The Dark Knight, readers got
to see one of Batman’s first failures, when
he wasn’t strong enough to save a kidnapped
girl from drowning.
Since he couldn’t forget the girl he had
let die, Batman turned to Venom – and his
slow descent into a laughing, grinning, and
out of control addict followed.
When he finally realizes that he’s gone
too far, Batman demands Alfred lock him in
the Batcave for a month, and not to let him
out for any reason.
Quitting cold turkey brought Bruce’s worst
demons to the surface, showing comic fans
that the heart of Batman was darker and more
damaged than most realize.
The Incredible Hulk: Monster (Marvel Comics)
Thanks to Ang Lee's first crack at a live-action
Hulk movie, audiences now know that the mild-mannered
Bruce Banner came from a truly broken home,
with a raging father who regularly beat both
Bruce and his mother, Rebecca.
That origin story was ripped from the pages
of Marvel Comics, but left out some of the
darkest parts.
Even though Bruce would only become the Hulk
when exposed to Gamma rays as an adult, his
father was convinced that Bruce's intelligence
at a young age was the result of radiation
he had passed onto him.
He was wrong, but beat the son he saw as a
monster and his mother anyway, eventually
killing Rebecca in front of Bruce.
When Bruce visited his mother's grave while
in college, his father appeared to blame him
all over again, and the fight between the
two ended with Bruce knocking his former abuser
into his mother’s headstone, killing him
instantly.
To cope with killing his own father, Bruce
just blocked it out, convincing himself for
years that his father had left to be killed
by muggers.
Maybe the Hulk wasn’t really the monster
side, after all?
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any dark, twisted, or troubling
comic arcs starring famous superheroes?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to get more videos like
this one.
If you love superheroes make sure you check
out our friends at SourcefedNERD and their
awesome Superhero Roundup show every Friday!
Click to watch their latest video and make
sure you subscribe to their channel while
you’re there!
Thanks!